The status code is 302, and the location header was this URL:
iana.org/domain/example.
Okay--I'll walk through how I found these answers,
and, hopefully, you did something similar.
So we go to our terminal, and we said example.com.
So let's make that request.
Telnet to www.example.com, port 80--okay--
now we say GET/HTTP/1.0
Host www.example.com--aha--
nice simple response.
We can see our status code is 302, and we can see
our location header is right here, iana.org.
If that didn't work--you know--here's how you do it.
Alright--so let's play around a little bit more,
so--we see that this is a redirect response because it was status code 302,
and it's saying the actual content is here.
Let's give a shot at making the request to find this,
we're going to telnet to iana.org and make a request for this path,
and see how it goes--see if we can get a 200.
We make the request to iana.org, telnet to www.iana.org, port 80,
and then we say GET/domain/example, HTTP/1.0.
Okay--so here we are.
You can see where I telnetted into iana.org,
and you can see the request I made for /domain/example,
I used HTTP 1.0 again, and you can see the response. [Laughs]
This is actually kind of funny.
So I responded with HTTP 1.0 status 200.
This is actually a good example of the web not lining up exactly correctly.
But--that's how it goes.
Generally, this 1.1 should have matched this 1.0,
but since these guys control the web I guess they can do whatever they like.
Okay--so--you can see the common headers, dates--you know--today,
[Laughs] actually, today for me--and the past for you.
You can see the server header, Apache,
you can see--this is an interesting header--last modified.
This page was last modified over a year ago.
This is for caching purposes.
This tells our browser that we don't need to bother
requesting this page again--you know--
we don't need new updates if it hasn't changed since this date.
Content type--this is typical--text HTML,
and below that, you see the content.
Pretty cool, huh?